au cinéma qui est un James Bond et il y
avait la nouvelle à son Martin Casino
Royale et j'étais sur les Champs-Élysées
et je vois le film j'ai dit je sors je
sors du du cinéma et je vais aller
directement acheter la voiture
je suis sortie du cinéma
je voudrais la la seule Martine de James
est-ce que vous l'avez oui monsieur
Castaldi j'ai fait un chèque et je l'ai
vu je vous j'ai fait un chèque
directement
j'ai pas eu pendant une semaine je l'ai
eu quoi huit mois après et il voulait
vivre il y a votre nom sur le moteur
comme ça et j'avais mis pigeon aussi et
et donc et donc j'avais acheté cette
voiture assez cher
380000 euros et en fait j'avais dit en
fait